so the 49ers it was two weeks ago now
again the weeks and days continue to
blur during this ongoing pandemic but it
was two weeks ago
that the 49ers moved from 12 to three
putting themselves in position to draft
a quarterback
we all believe or at least not all but
many many many are saying
many are saying that mac jones will be
the pick at number three
there was an interesting back and forth
earlier this week between dan patrick
and nick saban the i'm not going to be
the alabama coach alabama coach
on the pro day pro day two where mac
jones threw
kyle shanahan was there john lynch was
there 49ers coach in gm respectively
here's saban on whether under what
extent they had a conversation with him
about mack jones what did you tell kyle
shanahan about mac jones
he didn't ask me a thing didn't ask me a
thing i said hi to him
john lynch too they did not ask me
anything about them
they didn't ask me a thing wow maybe
they thought they weren't allowed to
because
you know out there on the pro day floor
which is where i saw them
yeah you know i think that they they i
don't know all their rules but i think
their wizards are not really allowed
to talk to me yeah that's not the rule
coaches and g
and gms are allowed to talk to college
coaches at pro days
urban meyer stood next to dabo swinney
for the entirety of listening to the
ball
whiz out of the hands of trevor lawrence
so i don't know what
nick saban's doing there i don't know if
he's trying to help cover up or whatever
and
just because he didn't talk to him there
even if they didn't talk to him there
they can talk to him whenever they want
to talk to him they can call him
whatever they want one of the things
saban said
a couple of years ago in a documentary
with bill belichick is i'm amazed
more college coaches are pro coaches
excuse me don't call me
to find out about the guys who have
played for me so
i the 49ers aren't going to take mac
jones without doing their full and
complete diligence peter so
i i just thought that was kind of odd
but
i don't think it means much as to what
the 49ers are thinking about doing
the reason i don't think it means
anything is that you know the 49ers
the one thing they don't want to do is
they don't want to show their hand
and so they're not going to glom on to
nick saban and spend
20 minutes with them at the pro day
grilling them
because there are other people around i
mean
what they do i'm sure absolutely sure
is you know call nick saban
uh or you know facetime or
or zoom with nick saban for a half hour
or 45 minutes to sort of ask him about
it but
i i'm gonna be a little bit naive and i
i don't mean to suggest that this is
what happened
they might have spent four hours talking
to nick saban at some point
or collectively but kyle shanahan
all he wants to do is scout the player
watch him you know study him as closely
as he can
and to do that all he's got to do is
watch whatever 17 games however many
games he played
at alabama watch every snap i'm sure
he's got
some questions about it hey on this play
what did you see
well he can ask he can ask mac jones
that
so without sounding trying to sound
naive
because clearly every head coach has
stuff that they can tell
you know his acquiring coach about him
i don't think it's that important for
them to to
grill nick saban for for very long and
i certainly don't think they would do it
on the floor
during his workout yeah i agree with you
completely and really when we think
about the draft that starts in 20 days
the biggest mystery right now is what
what the first mystery
is what will the 49ers do and to a
certain extent there's there's value in
milking that if you are
the 49ers because you get a lot of free
publicity
over the course of the next 20 days as
everyone is trying to figure out is it
mac jones
is it justin fields could it be trey
lance at number three
and the nfl has to like that too peter
because why are we tuning in
on thursday night first night of the
draft if we know
picks one two three don't need to tune
in for the first hour of the draft
we'll we'll be there for the falcons at
number four what are they gonna do so i
think the league probably a little bit
dismayed
that it's so obvious that it's trevor
lawrence and zach wilson one and two
but not dismayed that we don't know for
sure what the 49ers will do and we
definitely don't know what the falcons
are going to do they may trade out of
that spot they may use that pick if they
use that pick while they take a
quarterback
we simply do not know
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports